multiple teams had multiple picks five
ended up with two first round picks
let's see how they did or let me open it
up to you
between the Chargers Raiders dolphins
Vikings 49ers who did the best with
their two first round picks Chris to me
it would be between the Chargers and the
49ers I think if I had to go between
those two teams that would be the ones
that jump out to me you know of course
hey that the Chargers I look at it your
franchise quarterback and they got a
franchise have been a linebacker I mean
Murray is was a top 20 talent really and
the fact that he was there he's a
perfect scheme fit he's an athletic he's
long he's nitty and grays gritty in
between the tackles and tough he's not
your typical big 12 linebacker and then
the 49ers you know my I come in yes I
know I'm a little biased there but I
know my style [ __ ] a little bit but I
know you know I love Javon Kinlaw so
that's a major than they got him to get
to replace two for his Buckner but then
also I know my man Kyle Shanahan thought
Brandon I you from Arizona State could
be Isaac Bruce in the NFL and that's why
he loved him so much and they needed the
receiver position as we know they traded
for Emanuel Sanders he's gone they're a
little limited there and now you know
they got a little more depth and a
little more than a lot more talent at
the position you know and when you
consider the college Shanahan was a
receiver in college he knows a thing or
two about them he does what it takes to
be effective and I like the fact that
that they they made two trades last
night they moved from 13 down to 14 and
still got the guy they wanted by letting
the Buccaneers jump up and get Tristan
Dwarfs at number 13 so you pick up a
fourth round pick by doing that a fourth
round pick you didn't have and then you
trade up from 31 to 25 to get a uke
because apparently they were getting a
little nervous that somebody was going
to jump on the brand and a youth train
so they give up a little bit to jump up
six spots and get a youth before someone
else can grab them Chris so I like that
I like that creativity and now they do
have picks ago they have they now have
no picks in round two three and four
because they gave up the fourth round
and they got from the barriers as part
of the package to move up but still they
got two guys that they apparently really
wanted
look yeah now here's the thing I vividly
recall in 2017 when the 49ers got
Salomon Thomas and Reuben Foster and
John Lynch boasted to Peter King that
these were two of the top three players
on their board so you can thump your
chest all you want but if the guys can't
play or in the case a foster can't stay
out of trouble and get cut it doesn't
matter now we got to see if these guys
can play him for as much heat as the
Bears get for passing on Patrick with
Holmes and taking Mitchell true Biscay
the 49ers did take Solomon Thomas
instead of Patrick mahomes no yeah I
mean you're right but you know I think
they've proven that they can still be
pretty good without Patrick my homes
since they just play in the Super Bowl
with Patrick my homes they don't want
the super Patrick with Holmes I think
that's it I think that's safe to say -
I'm not so sure they would have lost the
game last year if they had Pachamama the
quarterback really but yeah I mean Mike
you're right with all these guys we're
gonna see how it plays out the Kinlaw
certainly has big-time ability and ayub
to it to your point Mike you're spot-on
with Kyle Shanahan
he's an X wide receiver he sees the game
through the wide receivers eyes he's
been around Julio Jones and Andre
Johnson and Houston and of course a
number of other great receivers he's got
a great eye for talent I always doubted
him and his expertise the wide receiver
position and he really liked this I you
kid and I think there was a lot of teams
hot on him towards the end of the first
round and I think that's probably what
made Lynch and Shanahan go weight you
know
is this guy gonna still be here at 31
let's go get the guy we really want we
you know accumulated a few more picks
like you said and they made the play to
get the guy that that ultimately they
saw is one of the best receivers in the
draft the Raiders gave us a little bit
of a surprise making Henry rug's the
dead lifts receiver taken at 12th
overall but then Damon Arnett the Ohio
State cornerback at number 19 a lot of
people were head scratching on that one
and he didn't show up on many if any
mock drafts and here's the thing it was
kind of a Cleveland feral moment for the
Raiders and if Farrell had worked out
last year and been great we say oh oh
here's Mayock again
pulling a rabbit out of the hat that no
one else was paying attention to because
of feral we're now gonna look at Damon
Arnett and say hmm hmm is it is this
this year's version of the guy that they
reach for who ends up not panning out I
certainly think it's a reach I mean and
you're right I mean last year they
killed it in the draft except with that
first pick in my opinion and yet when
you're the number four pick and you
draft a pass rusher and he's not on the
field and pass rushing situations
throughout most of the season that's a
little concerning
you know Damon Arnett is a real good
player I mean certainly a guy that I
looked at is like a top 45 top 50 pick
in the draft did I think this was too
early yes but you know one thing I think
we saw a little last night was I think
the NFL is putting more value in a
little these nickel corners then maybe
even myself or others in the media are
giving it credit for I mean we saw to
basically nickel corners at the end of
the first round with the Vikings and the
Dolphins making their pick who went off
the board and I think obviously they
need help and pass defense they are in
Oakland and they saw a guy that I think
can fill that void and fill that need
you are playing in the AFC West then you
got to deal with you know the Kansas
City Chiefs but you know Mike I just
it's like I would never draft a corner
who runs four or five seven at the
combine I just I wouldn't
it's like drafting a defense a nose
tackle who weighed in at 260 at the
combine it's just a little concerning
there's things I like he's really
explosive in short areas Mike like he
can really drive on the ball and break
on the ball that way but like is he
gonna be able to cover ha
you know Tyree kill when he runs a deep
route no Tyree kills gonna fly by him in
fact anybody that played went vertical
or this kitty he can be very he can be a
holder and a P I pass interference type
of guy too so yeah this was a little of
a head-scratcher for me for sure
dolphins had their three first-round
picks last night to a Tonga bellow at
number five Austin Jackson the USC
tackle at 18 and then a burn
cornerback Noah Igbo Nagin a at number
30 what did you think of what they did
with the free picks they had well yeah I
mean you know my thoughts onto uh and
you know say what you want I mean I like
to you know that some people think I'm a
hater unto okay we'll see we'll just see
how
plays out I did not think he was worth
the number five pick and of course with
the injury history no Austin Jackson is
really intriguing Mike because he has
all the tools to be in that conversation
for the top tackle in the draft it was
an underwhelming last season for him at
USC but I do give him the benefit of the
doubt he had a serious family issue he
donated bail bone marrows anybody
watched the draft class they donated it
to his sister you know I think that
probably did affect this play and I
think Miami probably has the inside
track that some of that informant
information and felt good about that but
has the tools the size the feet the
power everything to be really special
it's just last year was not his best
year on film well you know the Dolphins
have a long way to go but the door is
open with the Patriots losing Tom Brady
and they signed 10 free agents this year
in veteran free agency they are trying
their damnedest turns out they I wonder
I wonder how long it will be before two
is on the field because they like Ryan
Fitzpatrick Ryan Fitzpatrick is capable
of playing well in stretches III I'm
gonna be curious to see what their plan
is for putting two on the field because
look the time is always now in the NFL
show that he's healthy and if he can get
ready then maybe he ends up supplanting
Ryan Fitzpatrick and also you know well
for the second straight year
you've got Josh Rosen supplanted
potentially by a top five draft pick and
we haven't talked about him at all but
he probably will be on the move again
somewhere in the aftermath of the draft
Chris I would think so yep a team that's
looking for a good backup to maybe hit a
home run to say hey this guy could be a
starter maybe someday for us let's bring
them in yeah I think that could be a
very real possibility and have never mad
at a team if they think this
quarterbacks their guy you go and do it
yeah I don't think I would have done it
but I'm not mad at them for that thought
and then Mike just the last thing
because you talk about their free agency
right Byron Jones they signed exam bein
Howard last year is one of the best
corners in football they got two of the
top five or six corners on the roster
and then they drafted another
the league I mean and then drafted
another one I mean that's that's patriot
southeast right there they're trying to
take the rain for the best court best
corners the best secondary of all
football
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports